[Music]
in casting couch news Oh gross submitted
by Bob just Bob hey Bob I mean I
pretended to be a porn producer and
tricked women into having sex with him
and is now going to jail Oh gross dude
why is he going to jail I'm surprised
that more guys don't do this so people
lie all the time like hey I do this but
then whatever isn't it in that specific
category though maybe like grounds for
being like hey that's foreplay that's
like role-playing that's like hey I'm a
porn producer let's have sex
he's in trouble for saying he's a porn
producers so if you said he was a doctor
and they had sense in the BOK he has 21
federal counts again oh oh under what
charges did don't all the women give
consent
yeah that's not trying to figure out the
charge yeah tell me the story the crime
is is that he actually tricked women
into having sex with him when he was
just saying about yeah I'm a porn
producer like I'll give you this much of
money if you audition and then if you do
like a sex tape with me you get this
much money in this much so it's legal if
they the sex was actually like an
audition tape and it was to further
their career table oh well the thing is
though like when he was pretending to be
a porn producer like he actually like
forged documents like IRS documents oh
that's probably why he's made his
production more official like to make
girls believe like okay yeah like yeah
this seems pretty legit like me illegal
this stupid thing is he could have
actually just made oh yeah was he
releasing it or is this just for him so
he what created all did he actually pay
those girls did he pay let's go in order
Julia
his name is Mario Antoine and he's 34
years old here is like yeah like how
nice are the eyes yeah he's got great it
looks like he's part of the Nights Watch
or some looks like he lost a little
weight
he's from Winterfell yeah Winterfell oh
he took the oath man you know
Game of Thrones no oh you could tell cuz
I was like stone cold nobody said
anything like you didn't watch it you
were making fun of us for Harry Potter's
I'm still big he's waiting for a Chamber
of Secrets mm the funny part is not that
you're watching Harry Potter the funny
part is how later watching it I know
it's funny but I'm gonna watch it we're
watching my number two we're getting
there or I will moguls are now muggles
[Laughter]
we're sticking on muggles for at least
another three seconds good it can't be
worse cuz corner actually exists in our
world
so do moguls oh don't worry no the word
doesn't exist in the English language
that's moving on Julia so he tricked six
woman into sleeping with him with fake
promises of giving the money for like
their services like for like their
audition and then like whatever sexual
act a performed on him so he doesn't he
didn't pay that yeah yeah I mean yeah
you have a lot against them so it's just
so between the year of 2011 to 2016 he
actually created like a number of online
aliases to try to recruit these girls
and so like he'll pose as like telling
managers six women in five years I'm
just saying like this guy's must have
put a lot of work to my knowledge it's
at least six women gosh yeah so like
seven or eight
you should have been in Hollywood cuz
he's in Kansas not a lot of people in
the pointiest industry are there oh
maybe that's why they fell for it so
easily - so he'll pose as talent agents
managers like photographers for these
like pornography companies and the
companies that he created was like
playboy worldwide playboy Asia and like
he even created websites - like it would
be info at playboy Asia calm or
something that yeah doing this kind of
work super hard yeah why don't you just
be a better person
so he forced her I gotta be way easier I
know right that's a lot of work in time
and effort how long maybe he gets off on
like like suckering women or something
like the lie like that's the adrenaline
rush like while he's getting heavies
like you have no idea that I'm screwing
you for real for real you could have
totally just turned it thing into a like
porn site and really made something out
of it and it would have been a win-win
situation where the girls wanted to be
porn stars gray so just make a company
I'll let anyway secure about putting his
own personal videos up because he was
trying to have sex with them there for
the videos were coming from him that's
true and he's part of the Nights Watch
so he can't do that you can't do that
that would be violation how long is he
going to jail as of right now he'll be
sentenced to ten years so they might
lower it i we don't good behavior I
don't know what a sack of [ __ ] there's
too many guys out there that like resort
to such shady stuff just to get some
poon on a and it's weird to me so in
order to make his companies look legit
he actually forged IRS and Department of
Homeland Security documents just to make
it look pretty official right he spent a
lot of time on [ __ ] Photoshop he did
everything to make a fake company when
he could have just made a company yeah
those are all those right steps yeah you
could have made a website then the
Nights Watch not come the Nights Watch
at night well like this guy was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I hate it in
because so
do you know I hate him
now when you went to Kansas City laughs
I was reading it Dyckman I was reading
that Dyckman on him and so it's just
like oh my god he's such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] so he would actually have like
these victims like Siamese contracts and
they're thinking that these were
modeling contracts right and so he made
them sign it and then he would give them
rates right like oh you audition to make
a video that it would be like two K
right for a [ __ ] 8k so wait that's
way more money than I feel like normal
people are for a 30-minute sex tape like
intercourse that's like 12 K Plus is
what he was saying and so he would give
these races to women and the thing is
that the way that he would Scout these
women is he would create Facebook like
Facebook profiles of like him being like
a girl and there was one that he was
under the name of Niki and like he went
over and we're like oh hey you know um
you uh like you look like you could be
this like are you interested you know
like I know a friend of yours I was like
that participated in this and blah blah
blah right and so that's how he would do
it and like from the timeline of him
contacting each victim they were all
somewhere around the same time and like
he would constantly check up and follow
up with them like a couple weeks after
even if he didn't get a response I can
still like pursue them until like they
actually like Haven was like really like
they start asking questions like do you
really make that much like can you
really make that much and then like it's
like how how fast is the payment and
then he was like I mean three days at
most but typically you get on the second
day sometimes if you're lucky like the
next day right and so it it sucks
because like these victims like one of
the victims had a kid and like was
trying to also had a job and was just
trying to make extra money and
apparently like um she also had a
boyfriend too right and so when when
this victim refused to like shoot or
like film anymore with with Mario he
started threatening her and be like well
like and I was like well this isn't any
good you know and then like he would
send like a screenshot of like what she
did with him and then she was like well
that's not that's not
want it right and then he was like what
make you like you know like I could be
making millions off of these like photos
and like he was like literally talking
down on all these victims and so what
happened to this particular victim was
that he what he was so fed up with her
that he actually afford a picture of her
having sex with him
to her boyfriend it's just sad um
purport was like what the [ __ ] like do
you have anything better with your life
and then he was like like how's the like
of dating a porn star you know and then
or like or like beings but somebody that
does porn right so who's super yeah and
so then like uh the victim would be like
why did you do that you know like I lost
my job I lost my boyfriend and I have to
take care of a kid and you won't even
give me my money and so it was a lot of
controversy because a lot of the women
they're like waiting on their money but
like they were never getting I hope
someone in jail makes him makes him his
their little sex slave and every night
he gets a really large penis in his
mouth in his butthole over and over and
over and say you're gonna be a star and
he becomes the jail star and they call
him the [ __ ] back that's terrible that's
[ __ ] disgusting dude like that just
goes to show how this guy had such low
self esteem that he never thought that
he can actually get a woman like
normally that he had to resort to all
this crazy as diabolical [ __ ] to just my
head even in his internet researches
like you can see that he was trying to
find like oh is it illegal to like do
this and do that he had a chance because
even Megan would like damn I go for
there's women out there that only see
the positives aka Megan
good keep it up girl thanks coach cuz I
was like man this guy looks like a human
[ __ ] hamster yeah like if you're
gonna have one the patience to the wit
and three the drive to commitment that
much just for the sake of seducing a
woman then like I'm pretty confident you
be successful yep yeah he would have
killed it in business and or in romance
in some way or another not a lot of
people have that kind of discipline it
was just sex and still be successful
with that he had all the tools but it
just went in the wrong direction is he
convinced like he cold-called and
convinced like that's amazing
just for the six yeah you could have
been selling cars and you have great
money but he took it the wrong direction
you [ __ ] up buddy hello matter people
do you want to contact me and everybody
else you see go ahead and check the
description box below and follow our
social medias is the Gramps and
Twitter's for more videos click up there
baby
[Music]